what we know about being married is that
the minute you get married then everyone
starts asking when you're going to have
babies
so it's my time on entertainment tonight
you guys obviously are going to have you
know what the trip
well of course yeah i mean like i've had
i had like a baby doll when i was like
two days old like carrying around a
little doll
from baby doll to baby leah michelle
is officially a mom the actress and her
husband
zandy rich just welcomed their first
child into the world
the happy news comes after the couple
tied the knot in a romantic ceremony in
march 2019 near napa california
the two first began dating in july 2017
and zandy popped the question less than
a year later
how cute is that you should marry that
man i did and while the love birds keep
their relationship
pretty private back in april the 33 year
old shared
this pic with her man writing grateful
for this one
a few months earlier leah shared this
heartfelt post to zandi
calling him her forever valentine in the
caption
e.t first learned the news that leah and
her husband were expecting
back in april shortly after leah shared
the first pick of her baby bump on
instagram writing that she was so
grateful
since then the former glee star shared a
few snippets of her pregnancy along the
way
including this pic from mother's day
this post shower bathroom snap
and she posted this nap selfie admitting
she was getting
all the z's before the babe arrived but
her pregnancy wasn't all bliss
not long after announcing the happy news
leah faced
criticism for her support of the black
lives matter movement
with several former co-stars sharing
stories of bad behavior from the actress
over the years
leah apologized with a lengthy statement
on instagram that read in part
i am very sorry i will be better in the
future from this experience
weeks later she wound up deleting her
twitter account after fans called her
out for not posting anything about the
search for naya rivera
after she went missing in july but
before all that
and before the cat was out of the bag
leah told et
the secret to preventing people from
asking if she was pregnant
the best thing to do is just always hold
a glass of wine
oh is it anytime you see anybody when
you're walking into a room
then no one asks you no one asks right
or they're like oh well she's making
some interesting choices then
oh i see a sparkling water but always
just walk into a room with a glass of
red wine and then nobody asks
you any questions and in october leah
sat down with ryan seacrest
and said she was looking forward to
starting a family and
dressing her kiddos up for halloween
they're going to be like the cutest
things ever okay
i feel like like sushi is number one on
the list i want myself to be a sushi
yeah or like a little like a lion
or like a
everything cute and adorable i just i
want that for sure